welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the spider-man no way home
trailer changed the mcu game on several
fronts but most disruptive was the
return of alfred molina as doc ock last
seen drowning in the 2004 sam raimi
spider-man 2 previously considered a
separate film universe but you cannot
keep a theater nerd down if i were a
wealthy man
now doc ock of course isn't the only
returning face in this film with hints
of willem dafoe as norman osborne green
goblin jamie fox electro and lizard and
sandman all of these making it more
likely that past peter parker's toby
mcguire and andrew garfield might return
too but now that we know more about this
movie how would that happen well the
answer might actually be in doc ock's
odd greeting hello peter why would doc
ock say this to tom holland peter parker
when his peter parker looks like tobey
maguire and i think the answer to that
question plus a huge detail most folks
might have missed from the trailer might
reveal how this movie's multiverse logic
works exactly and in what form toby
maguire and andrew garfield could appear
now when it comes to doc saying hello
peter the go-to assumption is that this
is just another example of deceptive
trailer editing doc ock could actually
be in a different scene and be seeing
his peter parker in this moment played
by tobey maguire with that alternate
peter's body getting sucked into this
universe along with all the villains
we're seeing and then that way you could
look at this line as a clue that tobin
requires rumored cameo in this movie
could be happening a second explanation
is that doc ock's moment here is not the
moment of his arrival in this universe
but rather a scene later in the movie
after octavius has had some time to get
to know the peter of this universe
that's why he recognizes him but there
is a weirder and cooler explanation i
think that doc ock sees this peter
parker with the face and form of tobey
maguire despite us seeing him as tom
holland because notice peter's clothes
throughout the trailer peter street
clothes
a gray suit jacket a light blue shirt
and a dark blue tie almost exactly the
same outfit that toby maguire peter
parker wears in spider-man 3 from 2007
the night he sees mary jane's play the
venom symbiote finds him and when he
first battles harry osborne goblin the
necktie is a bit different but the shirt
and jacket are exactly the same
additionally i discovered upon re-watch
that peter's shoes in most of the shots
are the gray and black jordan 1 shadow
2.0 on the roof with mj and the frozen
sanctum with strange and during the
spell but in all the scenes we see of
them after the spell takes place like
when peter is wearing that suit jacket
peter is wearing different shoes blue
ones like he's wearing these shoes in
the shot dr strange pushes peter's soul
out of his body now i know a guy can
have multiple pairs of shoes sure i just
think it is interesting that in all the
shots before the spell it's one pair but
then after the spell another but hey
here's a dilemma you've got 10 minutes
to waste and you've already watched
every new rockstars video so what to do
well you grab your phone and you open up
mobile legends bang bang it's a
worldwide multiplayer online battle
arena game with super fun 5 vs 5 action
against real people it's got easy to use
controls you just need two fingers to
become a master within moments of
choosing my fighter i'm sore deep in a
battle my team is killing it this game
taking down enemy turrets and slaying
right and left the game moves fast with
10 second matchmaking and 10 minute
matches less boring wait time and
farming and more fun action they've done
all kinds of cool collaborations in the
past including with star wars king of
the fighters even manny pacquiao
starting august 24th they're doing a
special partnership with transformers
for a series of events including the
ability to get limited time skins of
optimus prime megatron and bumblebee the
game has over 1 billion downloads
worldwide and has over 100 heroes with
easy to master controls it's a moba game
for everyone come join the mlbd world
you will meet your favorite characters
here use gift code mlbb 2021 to claim
hero granger and free skins as gifts
download now in the trailer doctor
strange says the problem is you trying
to live two different lives referring to
peter's desire to have both a private
life as a student in a public life as an
avenger but in the context of this scene
strange is answering peter's question of
what just happened and i think he's
giving a metaphysical explanation of the
effects of that multiversal crossover as
part of that spell strange appeared to
use a strand of peter's hair similar to
the way strange used thor's hair to
conjure odin's location and the way
agatha used wanda's hair to conjure
another memory-based incantation that
would mean that whatever this spell was
designed to do it was based on peter
parker's unique identity and inner
desires his soul that means the way the
spell flips and collides the separate
universes together it does so upon the
axis of this soul the multiverse
collision could have sucked in alternate
peters and people close to those
alternate peters like his enemies and
loved ones and caused all of them to
respawn in this reality but in the case
of the peters converging on the subject
of the spell the one who cast this wish
mcu peter therefore each of the
alternate peters take the form of and
look like the head whose hair that was
plucked from tom holland peter however
to others from their home realities
those alternate peters look like the
original universe selves so to doc ock
this peter looks like toby maguire and
that's why doc ock recognizes him but
that would also be why this peter looked
so confused standing next to this
woman's car window as if seconds earlier
he was staring at his own reflection and
confused why it looked like tom holland
that could also explain why this peter
appears in the toby outfit and why peter
in this same outfit looks even more
confused in that murky dungeon that i
have theorized could be inside dr
strange's artifact pocket prison where
he traps extra dimensional entities if
this is toby peter that would be why
he's stuck here because his soul is from
another dimension like the rest of these
villains doctor strange detaching
peter's soul from his spider-man body
might not just be a disarming maneuver
but a way for strange to verify which
peter's soul is inhabiting this body now
this explanation could mean there are
multiple tom hollands swinging around
new york each with the soul of a
different universe as spider-man and
yeah this could be why we see one
spider-man in the far from home suit one
in the new black suit one in the iron
spider armor why would he need all of
them multiple peter parkers all of them
looking like tom holland but in the eyes
of the villains who fought them they
look like the actors who played that
particular peter parker so from our
point of view tom holland from norman
osborne and otto octavius's point of
view toby mcguire from the lizard and
electro's point of view andrew garfield
now alternatively there could just be
one tom holland peter parker in this
movie with different peter soules
jockeying for control of his mind and
that could be what strange meant by
peter living two different lives but i
don't know that kind of feels like the
sort of concept that marvel will explore
in moon knight instead but what i like
about this theory is that it helps
explain why tom holland was so adamant
that toby maguire and andrew garfield
would not be in this movie like they are
souls sharing a body all of toby maguire
and nature garfield scenes as
disembodied souls or alternate
perspectives of peter seen in his place
from different vantage points all of
that could have been shot separately
without tom holland ever sharing a set
with them now yes it does sound like a
production nightmare with dozens of
alternate versions of the script and
aura toby mcguire and andrew garfield
locked away in a closed-off green screen
set but also you could argue it's the
perfect spider-man movie for tom holland
a super secretive movie whose production
would be designed around his unique
tendency to blab plot secrets that would
require him to just simply show off that
signature naive bafflement that has made
his peter parker so endearing or maybe
he does know and he's just gotten really
good at keeping a secret fueled by the
prospect of being able to do slight
impressions of the peter parkers he grew
up watching inhabiting his body like
chris evans playing loki impersonating
cap now yeah it could just be way
simpler than i'm making it out to be and
toby mcguire and andrew garfield could
appear in their normal bodies separate
from tom hall and peter or they won't
cameo at all and peter's wardrobe is
just a weirdly specific homage or a
coincidence but if i've learned one
thing from doing this job folks there
are no coincidences just mephisto
occasionally gaslighting himself from
this title to the next one support new
rockstars by checking out our merch
options including our new what if
limited edition shirt you can get those
at newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
and subscribe to new rockstars thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you